now for the perfect way to ease yourself
into the day it's my guide to brunches
[Music]
brunch is simply a delicious combination
of breakfast and lunch and for me it's
all about getting up late and having a
wonderful lazy start to the weekend with
fantastic food
more exciting than breakfast and a lot
more enjoyable to cook brunch is ideal
for sharing
first up my simple and delicious
frittata
eggs are great they are so versatile and
once you've mastered how to cook them
trust me the door then opens to a wide
range of delicious options
this is like a triple omelette but a lot
more ingredients than a normal mesh
we'll start off with some lovely smoked
bacon slice
the bacon bacon in
those salts
little touch of pepper
start off on a high heat get that bacon
really nice and crispy
otherwise you just boil the bacon and
it's got that soft unpleasant texture in
the frittata
turn down the gas and now start adding
your veg
roughly chop a red pepper and add it to
the pan
the peppers and the bacon take the
longest so they've always got to go in
first
now soak them off
the peppers have been cooked now from
that sort of rendered fat from the bacon
and then
the spring onions just bunch them up
slice them i want them on an angle
so they come like little green diamonds
spring onions in
now
for the eggs cracking the eggs
for that size pan
seven or eight eggs
i want to fill it right to the very top
and more importantly when i
turn this out
i want it like a gato nice and thick so
slice through and see all those
wonderful verge
[Music]
i'm going to season the eggs
with some parmesan cheese be quite
generous because it adds a really nice
saltiness
[Music]
fresh ground pepper and then whisk
whisk up those eggs nicely
[Music]
then add peas to the pan
and to give the dish a wonderful
aromatic freshness some fragrant chopped
basil i want to chop that sort of
roughly
because i want to see those flecks of
green going in
i want it looking charming and how many
times have you seen a
dull omelet
frittatas in my mind really helped
encapsulate the magic of having
savory eggs
cooked beautifully
but with texture
now just before we add the eggs
i've got this
beautiful little
goat cheese and it's strong and powerful
so i want to slice it
into little chunks
and then just
have it
dotted around i want to discover these
little pockets of creamy goat's cheese
now slowly
add the eggs
[Music]
fill that right up
and get your spoon
now just let all that egg go down to the
bottom
bring it back up to the boil
and sort of clean around the sides and
then some of this delicious
salty
creamy goat's cheese over the top
now
i want it melting like a
a perfect
slice on toast
nice
now
from there turn the grill on for four to
five minutes
[Music]
now
just looking at that
delicious
take a little paring knife and just
make sure
it's released
on the sides
just take your panel
tap
that will hopefully release the frittata
from the bottom of the pan
now
the board over the panel
turn that
gently
and just
shake
say a little prayer
and lift off
back
beautiful
[Music]
now from there
on
there it's there look
now
slice
through
you can see how soft and creamy that is
in the center
and that goat's cheese is just melting
almost like a little sauce inside it's
so exciting but more importantly so easy
to do it's got texture it's got
creaminess and that for me will beat any
omelette for brunch
serve with a stack of hot buttered toast
and a steaming pot of coffee this easy
frittata turned the humble egg into the
perfect dish for kicking off the weekend
[Music]
eggs are really versatile protein packed
and delicious here are three more of my
favorite recipes to give your brunches a
tasty twist
[Music]
first up north african eggs
[Music]
add olive oil to a hot pan
and fry finely chopped onions and red
and green peppers
[Music]
then chop garlic
and chili
and cook until softened
chili's worked brilliantly with eggs
giving the dish a lovely hot kick
next add fresh chopped tomatoes
then cumin seeds and fry until the seeds
are fragrant and the tomatoes are lovely
and soft
season
next make wells in your spicy sauce
and crack in your eggs
then cover and cook on a low heat for
five minutes so the whites are set and
the yolks are still lovely and runny
to finish slice spring onions
and coriander and simply sprinkle over
fresh spicy and deliciously different
easy north african eggs
ready in under 20 minutes and this worth
getting up late for
next eggs made super indulgent for
brunch cheat souffle with three cheeses
[Music]
mix together flour
sugar
baking powder
and season
make it well in the center
then simply beat six eggs together
pour into the well and whisk into the
flour
then whisk in milk making the mixture
lovely and light
next add the three cheeses cottage
cheese
grated monterey jack or cheddar
[Music]
and cream cheese
and then for extra richness knobs of
butter
then butter a baking dish
and pour in your rich cheesy cheats
souffle mix
now put in a medium oven and bake for 40
minutes
until rich
golden and puffed to perfection
a stunning fuss-free souffle that's
ideal for brunch
my next easy egg dish is a salty and
succulent prawn and feta omelet
[Music]
pour olive oil into a hot pan
add chopped tomatoes
spring onions and fry
season
[Music]
next add cooked prawns
and a sprinkle of chilli flakes to give
it a lovely kick of heat cook through
and set aside
next beat four eggs
add olive oil to your frying pan and
pour in the eggs
sprinkle on freshly chopped oregano
which works brilliantly with eggs
then spoon over the spicy prawns
crumble over creamy feta cheese
and grill for a couple of minutes
this is eggs to the nth degree packed
with different tastes textures and
flavors
all working wonderfully together perfect
one super versatile ingredient three
mouthwateringly different recipes
brunch has never been better
nice
next my tricks to the trade and kitchen
tips
first up red pepper as you've seen great
for frittata and north african eggs but
you need to know how to cut them
properly
i absolutely love these peppers now they
have the most amazing sweet delicious
flavor with a really nice crunchy
texture and the most exciting thing
about the peppers is that they're just
as delicious raw or cooked to identify
the perfect pepper must be smooth and
firm and not a wrinkle inside now how to
cut the perfect pepper
stalk off
pepper down and get the knife start from
the top and slice all the way around
basically we're going to be slicing
around the seeds
look
no faffing around like this little
perfect christmas tree of seeds and you
haven't got the mess all over your board
and more importantly it's twice as quick
discard that now
we're going to cut it into a julienne
flatten the pepper
skin side down onto the board because
it's a lot easier to slice through the
pepper and just lift the knife
up and down
and basically julienne
is a chef's word
for strips
these
are absolutely perfect for sauteing and
that's what we're looking for there
crunchy delicious and more importantly
no seeds beautiful
many great brunch recipes start with a
delicious fresh egg my tried and tested
way to tell if your egg is fresh is to
simply place it into a bowl of cold
water a fresh egg will sink and a stale
one will float
if a small piece of shell goes into the
bowl when you're cracking eggs my tip
for removing it is to simply use a
larger piece to fish it out it works
like magic
for prize winning fried eggs fry them in
oil adding a tablespoon of water then
cover the water steams the top of the
egg to perfection
toasted bagels are brilliant for brunch
my tip to make sure you always have them
on hand is to stock up your freezer
but make sure you slice them first that
way you can pop them straight into your
toaster
[Music]
this is my ultimate cookery course a
hundred recipes to stake your life on
i'm about to show you my recipe for
delicious spicy pancakes tuck it
underneath there pull it back
and roll but first here's my guide to
buying beautiful eggs knowledge is
crucial the more you know about where
your ingredients are from and how they
produce the better in my home kitchen i
use eggs in abundance they are so
versatile and getting to grips with them
will make your cooking sing
girlies
with a decade of experience under her
belt helen from harrah's farm in
hertfordshire is a real egghead and has
some valuable tips to share
the hens we keep are designed to lay
probably
300 350 eggs a year
free range means that the bird must have
access to the outside at all times
chickens love grass they peck it
whatever's on the ground and it makes
the eggs a lovely rich golden color
and the flavour is tremendous
to tell if an egg is really fresh crack
it open put it on a dish and you will
see that it sits up really quite high
and the white is really nice and tight
around the side of the yoke
there's a vast range of eggs out there
to experiment with
why stick to what you know try living up
your brunches with something different
this is a bantum egg they are miniature
chickens the yolks are quite large
compared to the whites of the egg and
they're absolutely delicious making
scrambled eggs of them because they're
much more creamier
all together than
say a chicken's egg
this is the duck's egg these ones are
sort of an off-white color but they can
be
sort of creamy greeny colors compared to
chicken eggs the duck's yolk is richer
and creamier and the white is fluffier
when whisks which is why they're so
incredible for bacon this is the
goofs egg this is quite a large egg it's
probably equivalent to
three chicken eggs the geese literally
lay for about 12 weeks
from my few geese we've had about 120
eggs they're amazing layers but just for
the very short season the amazing thing
is the color of the yolks of these they
are usually quite orange the geese don't
actually eat anything other than grass
they are just grazers and that makes a
huge difference to the color of the yolk
another fantastic egg is the quail egg
tiny but incredibly tasty they only take
a minute to soft boil and are delicious
dipped in celery salt
if you've got a big appetite or you're
making a brunch for a big group of
friends you could try the giant rare egg
from south america the equivalent of 10
hen eggs they're great scrambled or as a
massive omelet
another interesting option is the
pheasant egg small but rich in flavor
they're perfect for homemade scotch eggs
or hard boiled in a salad
you can keep eggs in your fridge
but ideally when you go to use them take
them out bring them up to room
temperature because you'll find that
they will cook better just make sure
that there's no cracks in them and then
you'll be
assured that they're nice healthy
tasting eggs
[Music]
brunch should be a laid-back affair and
a treat so the dishes need to be easy to
cook but never boring
my next recipe takes the humble pancake
to a whole new level of flavor and
excitement
soft fiery and irresistible
spicy pancakes
one of the secrets to good cooking is
learning to use your imagination when it
comes to brunches you don't have to
stick to the old standbys these
delicious spicy pancakes are really
great alternative but more importantly
so easy to do
start off by toasting your cumin
[Music]
it's a dry roast basically non-stick pan
just a touch of seasoning
the salt helps to dry out the cumin even
more
and then fresh ginger slice them nice
and thinly
stack it back up
and then just slice nice little thin
slices in there
and then keep that bunched up
shake the chilli
removing the seeds will prevent things
getting too hot
now
garlic
nice now
add olive oil to your toasted cumin
seeds and then with the garlic ginger
and chili lovely
[Music]
and it feels strange when you talk about
garlic for breakfast but the time i
spent in india
everybody was eating something savory
for breakfast it was extraordinary
into your bowl
and set aside
next the pancake filling add olive oil
to a hot pan
mustard seeds in now they'll start
dancing the minute they hit the pan
then finely slice an onion
onions in
a little teaspoon of turmeric sprinkle
that in
and look at the color
an instant change
leftover potatoes
just slice them
the smell is incredible potatoes in now
spread the potatoes across the pan all
the potatoes stained i want them sort of
absorbing all that really nice turmeric
actually like a sponge
season those potatoes and it really
helps to bring out
the spice beautifully
they're ready
turn off the gas and let them sit there
and absorb all those flavors
back to the pancake batter add plain
flour to your cooled garlic chili ginger
and cumin seeds
a touch of salt
and pepper nothing worse than the bland
pancake
one whole egg
milk
hold the jug with one hand and whisk
with a secret to get that really nice
smooth paste
but
whisk in that egg first and brings it
together
and then you're milking
don't put all the milk in because then
you're gonna get a lumpy pancake mix
and if you put less milk in
it really helps it
not going lumpy
look at that
milk here
the secret for me is to have a nice thin
mix
now just
a little teaspoon
of oil that helps to bring
a nice crispy edge to the mixture
now just taste it
that's the texture pan on
the larger the pan the better it helps
to create a nice thin even surface i
want that mix going all the way around
the pan before you put the mixture into
the pan make sure you give your pancake
mix a really nice stir
pan it's nice and hot
turn down the gas
a touch of olive oil in get that nice
whisk with one hand
pan to the mix
in
one and a half ladles
and then roll it around which is really
nice and thin i want to see the ginger
the garlic that's what i'm looking for
in there now back onto the heat it only
starts to remove from the bottom of the
pan and lifts itself up once it's cooked
these little bubbles
confirm that it's just starting to lift
off
the pan
a little shake that releases it and then
just shake it to the end
and toss
if you haven't got the confidence
tossing then use a spatula and turn it
over now
that's exactly what i want that nice
sort of crisp edge around the side the
color on the pancake is so important
now
roll it round
and just let it slide out
beautifully
now
for the exciting part filling them
take your potatoes
just sort of
have a really nice imaginary line and
then just very carefully
roll that
nice
and tightly tuck it underneath there
pull it back
and roll
the delicious pancakes are ready to eat
but with a simple dipping sauce they'll
be a real treat just mix chopped
coriander with natural yogurt
that's really nice cooling agent sit
there on the side
and that for me is a great brunch
delicious spicy pancakes
amazing
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
bursting with valuable lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stake your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stay good life
right now it's all about outstanding
brunches
i love brunch it's a great way of
relaxing with friends and family not
taking yourself or anything else too
seriously
and brunch dishes should reflect that
spicy sweet or savory anything goes
and one of my all-time favorites a dish
that always creates a stir is the daddy
of all brunches
steak sandwiches
[Music]
for me the secret of a great brunch is
fun and casual fuss-free cooking and
everyone helping themselves
this is the ultimate steak sandwich
you want the rolls royce of beef
it has to be fillet
now season it beautifully
i like to open up
the top of the peppermill to increase
the size of the pepper in the steak so
it gives that bit of heat
nice little chunks
you just roll now
nicely all the way around
now slice the garlic
in half
pan nice and hot
olive oil in
[Music]
hold the steak and just place it into
the pan don't drop it at the front of
the pan
we're going to tilt the pan forward to
cook the back of the steak dual purpose
now roll it back
and sear underneath
next
my garlic
and roast that garlic
time
fry that time i want to hear it we're
not looking for a lot of color because
you're going to dry out the fill it
so
just
one end
turn it back down
and stir the other end in
lift up your time place it on top of the
garlic
there
lift up your fillet
and sit there on
top
of your garlic
butter in
take a spoon
tilt the pan gently
lift up
and baste
i've got that scented garlic
thyme flavor
the steak is going to cook evenly
because it's sat on a little
a little bed
in the oven for 8 to 10 minutes
[Music]
pan on
for the relish you think of a steak
sandwich you think of a sort of nice
heated tomato relish
to make the relish finely dice a red
onion three finger rule one in front
two behind
through
and chop
wow
next roughly chop a chilli keeping the
seeds in for extra heat start off with
the olive oil
into a pan
onions
chili
[Music]
generous with the olive oil
i want a nice sort of rich
silky relish
from there
take your tomatoes you can't just use
red tomatoes but these yellow
and red make the perfect combination
now put your salt in
pepper
and then
roast those tomatoes off
take a wooden spoon and just sort of
break them up
once the skins blister
the whole tomato just starts to release
all that really nice sweet texture
a little teaspoon of cherry vinegar
gives that nice acidic balance the
sweetness
of the tomatoes turn down the gas and
just let them sort of stew perfectly
now a steak sandwich would not be
complete unless it had the most amazing
mustard mayonnaise
simply add three tablespoons of
mayonnaise to three teaspoons of whole
grain mustard
[Music]
now i've got the reddish almost down to
like a really nice jam
now
i want to make that relish a little bit
more fragrant
some basil
slice it through
and sprinkle that basil in there
[Music]
beautiful
look at this
there she is
my crown jewels
time to take it out
smell
is incredible
just baste one more time
to fill it
touch is quite soft in the center so
it's just coming up to mid-rare let it
rest the same time you cooked it it'll
be nice and pink evenly throughout the
steak
to make my sandwich i'm going to char
grill some sliced chipatta bread season
it nicely
just a little drizzle of olive oil i
want to get that bread nice and crispy
pan nice and hot
bread
in
push it down
smell is amazing that char sort of
charcoal flavor once you've got those
marks on the bread it just stops the
bread from becoming soggy and look at
this here
it is
stunning
on
slice it
gently
one beautiful slice
wow
it's nice and pink all the way through
and the beef is so soft
it's almost like slicing through butter
let the knife do the work
take
a little bit of mayonnaise spread that
the back of the spoon
on both sides
next
lettuce
take that beautiful slice of beef
and then relish
on top of that beef and just slice the
sandwich in half
beautiful
now that's what i call a steak sandwich
trust me serve the sublime sandwich for
brunch and you'll put a smile on
everyone's face
[Music]
next up my guide to buying the best beef
and steaks
if you want the ultimate brunch you
can't do any better than start with a
perfect steak and one man who really
knows his steak is master butcher danny
lidgate steak is my favorite type of
meat and i think it's really good to
enjoy different varieties of steak when
choosing a steak that you want you need
to look at exactly what you want out of
it
for my ultimate steak sandwich i used to
fill it because it's the most tender
the fillet does the least amount of work
than all the other muscles is tucked
away in the ribcage this means that when
you're buying a fillet
it's incredibly soft like butter it's
the most expensive but you get what you
pay for
there's a wide array of cuts to choose
from all different in taste and texture
if in doubt ask your butcher
this would be the rump section where the
rump comes from
which is basically the back side take
the bone out and what you're left with
is a wonderful steak rum steak
characteristically a little bit tougher
than the sirloin or a little bit chewier
than the ribeye but a really strong
flavor for the steak again when frying
rum look for the marbling try and get
some fat covering on the steak you can
always cut it off after it's cooked
rumps one of the best value steaks i
love it thinly cut and flash fried in
stir fries or simply marinated and
whacked on the barbecue another great
value but delicious cut is the hangar
steak known as the butcher's cut because
they often keep it for themselves it's
great marinated and cooked quickly
with the sirloin which is basically the
back of the animal a nice sirloin like
this really well marbled don't buy too
lean so once the sirloin is trimmed up
it looks something like this
not too much fat
but you need a little bit to cooking it
next to the sirloin
is the rib really popular now with eyes
small
nice
really tender juicy steaks it's really
especially good for barbecuing or
grilling fantastic probably my favorite
steak would be a rib eye
rib eye is especially delicious because
the marbling in the meat loads it with
flavor
for a full-on steak experience try the
t-bone steak with a small tender fillet
steak on one side of the bone and a
larger flavoursome sirloin on the other
[Music]
take your butcher's advice and you won't
go wrong the final word has to go to
danny
when buying me knowledge really is power
so it's important to ask as many
questions about the meet you're buying
find out the breed how it's aged and
decide exactly what you want to do each
particular job that should then give you
a really amazing end product
[Music]
the great thing about brunch is there
are no rules the only thing i insist on
are it's got to be fuss-free easy to
cook and so delicious it puts you in a
good mood for the rest of the day
and for me pancakes always hit the spot
here are three of my deliciously
different recipes certified to liven up
your mornings first up fluffy blueberry
and ricotta pancakes with yogurt
[Music]
start by adding 125 grams of plain flour
a teaspoon of baking powder
a pinch of salt a tablespoon of sugar
then create a wet in the center
separate two eggs and add the yolks
keeping the whites for later beat the
yolks into the flour pouring in milk
gradually to form a smooth batter
[Music]
next fold in 125 grams of creamy ricotta
cheese and 100 grams of fresh
blueberries
[Music]
now whisk your egg whites until they
almost reach soft peaks
then gently fold into the pancake mix
keep it in the air to make sure the
pancakes are extra light and really
fluffy
add olive oil and butter into a hot pan
then spoon in the mix to make small
pancakes cooking until golden brown on
both sides
to finish top with greek yogurt
fresh blueberries
and drizzle over lovely runny honey
sweet savory fruity and delicious made
in 15 minutes perfect brunch pancakes
my second simple pancake brunch recipe
is
succulent crab and mascarpone crepes
[Music]
for the filling put cooked white crab
meat into a bowl add in mascarpone
the zest and juice of a lemon
finely chopped chives and for a spicy
hit cayenne pepper
stir
and set aside
for the pancake batter simply add flour
salt
an egg
and milk
then whisk into a smooth mixture
add oil to a hot nonstick pan
ladle in batter to cover the bottom and
swirl it around spreading out nice and
thinly
when lovely and golden flip over turn
out and spoon the delicious crab mix
into the center of the pancake and roll
finally sprinkle with some chopped
chives and devour
my second pancake recipe grab a
mascarpone crepes a fantastic easy
brunch cooked in minutes
[Music]
when you want your pancakes sweet and
zingy this recipe is perfect
coconut pancakes with mango and lime
syrup
[Music]
for the lime syrup simply add water
cast the sugar
the zest and juice of the lime and
simmer for 10 minutes
to make the easy pancake batter put
flour
baking powder and desiccated coconut
into a bowl then crack in an egg
add coconut milk
and whisk into the batter until well
combined
sweeten with runny honey
now you're ready to fry add melted
butter to a hot pan place in heap
teaspoons of batter flip and cook until
golden
for a lovely vibrant wake up serve with
sliced fresh mango and drizzle over the
gorgeous citrusy syrup
sweet sticky and utterly irresistible
ready in under 20 minutes the ultimate
indulgent pancakes
[Music]
fast to prepare easy to make three
effortless recipes guaranteed to bring
some sparkle to your brunches
incredible welcome back to my ultimate
cookery course
i'm teaching you all about brunches the
most laid-back meal of the week and if
you want to take it easy having the
right equipment makes all the difference
[Music]
here's my guide to the best kitchen
equipment
everything you need to know about the
basic kit that will get you cooking
fantastic food
chopping boards
for brunch one of the most useful things
is a great chopping board get the right
one and it'll be your friend for life
i prefer a sort of heavy duty one
because they're so much more durable
they can be flipped over the minute you
want to go from vegetables to prepping
fish or meat always keep a little jake
off underneath that actually stops
the board from sliding
carefully wooden board by rubbing it
with oil every so often any cooking oil
will do wooden boards for me are always
the best easy to clean and long lasting
when you do wash your wooden board never
let it stand in water or put it in the
dishwasher as it may split buy the best
you can afford and take good care of it
[Music]
for brunch i'd love something sweet and
i've always been a fan of classic
british crumpets with butter and jam
but once you try cooking them at home
you'll never want to buy them from shops
again
this is another great recipe you can
stake your life on
it's my homemade crumpet
whether you're cooking for two three or
even a gang some of the best brunch
dishes are always the simplest
these crumpets are absolutely delicious
and it's a great end to a fantastic
brunch
first off we're gonna make the mix
what do you think of
growing up
the smell
and the taste of amazing crumpet
and never leaves you
to make the mix the secret is to bring
the milk up the ball but do not boil it
the minute it boils turn it off and let
it sit there now
flour in
a nice pinch of salt in
now add half a teaspoon of bicarb
that gives it aeration and really lifts
the mixture up all those lovely little
holes a nice pinch of sugar
and then
a teaspoon of yeast dry yeast
now once the milk's boiled turn it off
and add some warm water
about 10 tablespoons 150 mil
that cools down the milk
but more importantly it doesn't destroy
the yeast
half
of the milk in first stop
and give that a really good mix
now the rest of it
[Music]
[Music]
you can just see that there's no lumps
through there as it drips through the
whisk now we're looking for it to double
in size and get nice and light so pop in
a warm place whilst you get on with the
delicious topping
[Music]
beautiful strawberries but caramelized
almost like a very quick strawberry jam
hang on
[Music]
just slice these
in half
some sugar a couple of tablespoons
we're gonna take the sugar to a nice
light caramel it's just starting to
change color now
turn the gas down and we're gonna add
the strawberries
beautiful
just sweating the strawberries down
quickly and the caramel's breaking down
a wonderful glaze
on the strawberries
some lemon
grated into the strawberries
gives it that kind of freshness
that really
starts to break down the strawberries
nice
gas up
smells incredible some lemon juice
a touch of balsamo vinegar
and that gives it that really nice
delicious tartness now
off it goes
as the strawberries start to cool down
it will naturally thicken and
set beautifully
nice
[Music]
now for the crumpet
it's almost doubled in size but be very
careful you don't knock the bowl because
it can sort of push out all that air
it's aerated it's nice it's light
just see
the texture
she's ready to go
did you boil it
here we go
instead of making normal small crumpets
i'm making a giant one ideal for sharing
now turn the gas down
you can just start to see a traditional
crumpet-style
cooking process we want those nice
tiny little holes on top and that crispy
crunchy base
right now
it's time to add the butter just slide
the butter
down the back
that gives it a really nice nutty flavor
at the end
fish nice
flip beautiful
take that out
take the jam
spoon over
the secret is for the juice to sort of
run inside all those little holes
think of that tartness of the
balsamic vinegar the strawberries
beautifully
soft
and almost pureed
wrapped in that delicious
caramel
now
finish that
with a nice ball of creme fraiche
let that
sit there
and that
is an amazing way of finishing off a
traditional brunch
with something sweet something delicious
and something you're dying to tuck into
[Music]
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips
fruit can be a great healthy option for
brunch and knowing how to get the best
out of it can make all the difference
first up how to peel and cut a mango the
easy way
holding your stalk end up cut either
side of the stone cut all the way into
the flesh making squares without cutting
through the skin then turn it inside out
and carefully cut your pieces off
a great tip to check if a pineapple is
ripe is to pull a leaf out from the top
if it comes away easily it's ripe and
ready for slicing
my tip to get the flesh out of a kiwi is
to simply cut the fruit in half and
scoop it out with a teaspoon
try it it really works
if you have fruit that's not perfectly
ripe the tip is to put a banana in a
paper bag then add your unripe fruit put
it in a dark place and the banana will
speed up the ripening process of the
other
fruit you can make a great fruit puree
to accompany a brunch pancake or a
crumpet in a blender to clean it
afterwards add a cup of warm water and
run the machine for a few seconds empty
out then simply repeat with a drop of
washing up liquid then rinse
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
bursting with valuable lessons
top tips and 100 recipes just take your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
you